discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact and to grow and do amazing
things you know you can do amazing
things what's missing discipline there's
just a lack of follow through it's a
constant start and stop and start and
stop and start and stop and for me
there's nothing more not just
frustrating but sad than seeing somebody
who's got so much talent and so much
potential and so much of a heart and
just seeing them not win because they're
not following through because you're
just not doing the consistent enough
work that you're motivated and inspired
and then and then you're not anymore and
nothing happens